but today we saw startling new evidence
of the ravages of the pandemic in india
now it was already a dire situation the
government reporting more than 415
000 people have died but most infectious
disease experts agree the real toll is
almost certainly much higher
today the washington-based center for
global development released the most
comprehensive study on the impact of the
coronavirus in india
and as feared it says india's death toll
could be a staggering
10 times higher than the official tally
that would mean 4.7 million additional
deaths
from the start of the pandemic until
june of this year
just a few months ago india saw a
devastating rise in infections driven
largely by the more
infectious delta bearing
joining us now is one of the authors of
that report abhishek anand is a graduate
of harvard's kennedy school and he has
worked as a policy analyst for the
indian government he joins me tonight
from delhi it's good to have you on the
program
we knew that india's covert related
deaths were higher than the official
figures but
were you surprised were you shocked at
what came out of your
research i mean we're talking about
nearly 5 million
extra deaths
yeah we were surprised to be frank
because
i mean the primary because people have
been talking about second wave which we
had in india which lasted from around
may to
late june and people knew that the
official
estimates were quite an undercover but
what
was surprising for us that even in the
first wave which started
in around say april and went on till
around august september
the number of deaths that we finally
found based on our different estimates
was very very high so it was very
surprising for us and mr anand
what you've described in your report
i mean it could be india's worst human
tragedy in modern times i mean we want
to let that sink in
for a moment in modern times what has
been the response
there to this possibility
unfortunately i think we are still
lacking in response in terms of
policy as well as targeting people
reaching out to people who have actually
suffered
so uh first of all what the government
needs to do to accept the fact that
there has been lot more debts than what
is commonly believed because only once
you accept it
you can have targeted intervention you
can also prepare better for the future
and also maybe the vaccination drive
should be much faster than what it is
right now
so i just hope that in future taking
lessons from maybe
what our results show and also make sure
the results are coming up now
hopefully government will be much more
proactive and
also the policy response will be better
than what it has been so far
well talk to me about um how difficult
it was to gather
this information we're wondering why
you know official figures are always so
far off
in india when we're talking about the
corona virus
so yeah so there are many reasons uh in
fact why
official numbers could be an undercount
one
reason is in uh rural india basically
the
infrastructure is not proper the health
infrastructure so until unless
somebody gets tested gets admitted in
hospital and gets treated you never get
to know whether a person died of kovid
or any other
issue what we found in our study is that
people earlier believed that
it was much more of a city phenomenon
more in urban areas
but we see in our result that i mean
equal number of people have been
affected in rural areas as well
and because we can't really reach out to
people in rural areas they cannot get
tested
so i mean obviously that leads to an
undercount to such an extent
i mean is it possible that the the
national government
of narendra modi is trying to minimalize
the extent of the crisis
with its lacks approach to covet 19
statistics i mean is there an
argument that you could make there that
they that they're
almost profiting from the fact that
gathering certificates
or statistics is so difficult
uh to be fair i think the problem is not
just with this government
given our infrastructure that we have in
place i think it would have been
difficult for any other government and
in
general you are also right i mean
government would want to show a lower
number
but i believe any other government would
have found it difficult just because you
cannot really test people
and in a pandemic here it also takes
time to come out with actual number
because you know debt registry takes
time
because now we are actually getting
numbers one of the methods that we rely
on is basically using official
uh debts that have been registered now
because there was a prolonged lockdown
so it was difficult for people to come
out and get there if there was any death
in the family to get registered
so hopefully with time uh that delay
that we have seen so far
that will not be the case uh but let's
let's see how it goes
okay anand we appreciate your time
and your insights tonight we appreciate
you staying up so
late to talk with us thank you thanks
thanks so much
you